for this exercise we're going to be
discussing Batman's behavior in Zack
Snyder's Batman V Superman dawn of
Justice first we're going to settle the
question of does Batman kill and then
afterwards we're going to discuss the
implications for convenience I have
added a timecode burnin if you would
like to find these shots and examine
their context for yourself for the most
part we will be tracking casualties
people bailed severe or life-threatening
injuries and only count fatalities in
cases that are either confirmed or where
survival would be considered miraculous
so the first of note comes in our
introduction to Snyder's Batman with the
human trafficker that Batman brands
later through a package sent to Clark
Kent we learned that people branded in
this way are killed in prison a
dimension the Batman is clearly aware of
as he threatens Lex with branding at the
end of the film so while this murder is
not immediately performed by Batman he
is clearly complicit or the very least
willfully negligent in regards to it
next in order to track this correctly
within the chaos that follows we need to
pay attention to both of these cars
noting that they're both in motion and
pulled to a stop car a on the left is
hard to read but given that it drove up
with car B there is at minimum a driver
Batman in his Batmobile speeds down the
ramp with the intent of ramming car B
which pulls away in time for the
Batmobiles collide with car a instead
this collision strikes the driver's side
of the car square on the driver's door
with enough force to launch the car
through the air and a roll over it is
then harpooned and dragged for several
blocks if the driver of car a isn't dead
from all of that then they are almost
certainly finished off when Batman
releases the harpoon in order to draw
car a onto the driver and three
passengers in car B while all are likely
injured from this the impact is
concentrated over the rear seat of the
vehicle almost certainly killing the two
passengers sitting there this chain gun
equipped convertible SUV is occupied by
a driver and gunner when Batman first
shreds the vehicle with machine-gun fire
inducing a flaming roll over and then
drives clear through the vehicle
vaporizing it in a fireball in the most
contentious but included for completion
this sedan occupied by a driver and a
gunner collides with the tanker truck is
self occupied by at minimum a driver
which explodes almost certainly killing
all three however given that the
collision itself is the immediate
product of the drivers inattention these
deaths are disqualified
five from the overall tally next up the
Batmobile launches out of the second
story of a processing plant shearing off
a substantial chunk of the rear of this
truck including this man's head and
immediately broadsiding a van occupied
by a driver into gunner the collision
with the passenger side almost certainly
kills the gunner though the fate of the
driver is unknown moving ahead a few
days within the film's chronology Batman
assaults LexCorp leaving a trail of
mayhem in his wake while an accurate
count is difficult to parse as we only
see the aftermath of the point where
emergency services have been doing their
work for a substantial amount of time
there are nine confirmed casualties
eight of whom are leaving on the
stretcher in sub climax 3 V Batman hops
into the batwing and guns down three men
outside the warehouse Alfred says inside
the warehouse are two dozen hostiles but
Batman only fights 17 of them in order
of immediate life-threatening injuries
thug a has dropped a good 10 to 15 feet
to the floor below thug B is harpooned
through the leg and suspended upside
down thugs see is harpooned through the
chest dragged punched in the face and
then dropped to the lower floor thug D
is stabbed with a Batarang thug B is
kicked in the head hard enough to knock
him into thug he who drops his grenade
decisively killing them both F is
punched in the head hard enough to cause
unconsciousness G is slammed into the
ground with enough force to break
through the floor H has his head slammed
into a crate I is hit by a flying crate
J is stabbed in the leg K is punched in
the head L is punched in the head and J
is rammed headfirst into the ground hard
enough to break floorboards L getting
back up is slammed face-first into the
ground and punched in the head
repeatedly Em's arm is shattered and is
stabbed into the chest
o is punched in the face and thrown
through a wall and finally P and Q are
incinerated by an exploding propane tank
in the finale Batman intentionally lers
doomsday - or making Batman responsible
through negligence for the deaths of an
unknown number of security guards
homeless and transient people in the
area because abandoned doesn't mean
empty now you may be wondering why does
any of that matter aside from curiosity
and well it kind of doesn't which is
strangely why it matters see a general
feature of the Batman mythology is that
Batman doesn't kill now this isn't a
core rule and in many adaptations of the
character Batman either kills directly
and with intent or simply indirectly
through inaction
or leaving people in fatal circumstances
taken as a whole Batman has been many
different things at different times
which is fine it simply means that
Batman in any given adaptation needs to
be approached as he exists within that
adaptation before that adaptation can be
approached as it exists within the
context of the broader mythology there's
a weird number of people out there who
insists that Batman in Batman V Superman
doesn't kill anyone which is clearly an
absurd claim to make the evidence is
unambiguous now the point of this isn't
to harp on those people but rather to
illustrate why it is important when
approaching a text to approach it as it
actually exists and not as you hope or
wish it exists that aspect the Batman is
willing to kill and quite cavalierly
willing at that is simply a fact of the
text that needs to be accepted before
the film can be accurately
contextualized whether or not this is a
good or bad thing from a storytelling
perspective isn't really an objective
factor through a certain lens it may be
appropriate as an alternative telling of
Batman one that is far more extreme than
recent portrayals for mainline Batman
fans it may be inappropriate because
Batman vs Superman positions itself
implicitly as a central Canon for
industry watches it may simply be seen
as a poor choice for the foundations of
a flagship franchise this is why in
criticism it is important for the reader
to understand what lens the critic is
applying and for the critic to
effectively communicate their own
framework the fact that Batman kills in
Snyder's universe is not de facto a poor
creative choice however for a great many
critics and viewers it was the wrong
choice for the context that Batman vs
Superman tries to occupy
[Music]
you
[Music]